Back in the mid-nineties,
Microsoft wanted Windows 95 in
every home.
That's why they hired "Friends"
stars Matthew Perry and Jennifer
Aniston to teach people about
the sexy, fun world of the PC
operating system.
And could it be any more
hilarious?
>> Okay, now let's load up the
task bar.
I'll show you what it does.
>> Task bar?
Is that anything like a Snickers
bar?
Does that have nougat?
>> What is nougat?
Does anybody know that?
(silly tune plays)
>> HARDWICK: Aw, Jesus.
(laughter)
This lady's like, "Goddamn it!
I knew we should have gotten
Frasier.
Why did we do this?"
>> Oh, my God.
>> HARDWICK: Ah, it's not their
fault.
Comedian, "Friends" ep...
I mean, you know, they did this
corporate gig.
They probably got paid a shit
ton of money, and they were
like, "Well, no one's ever gonna
see this."
>> This looks like it's 50 years
ago.
Like, Jennifer Aniston looks
like a Puerto Rican bank teller
bad at math.
(laughter)
Like, what is...?
She looks so different now!
>> HARDWICK: I know.
>> She used to eat.
Comedians, "Friends" episodes
were always titled things like,
"The One Where Joey Moves Out,"
or "The One with the Chicken
Pox."
What is this episode called?
Jamie.
>> Uh, "The One Where Rachel
Dates a Nigerian Prince."
>> HARDWICK: Yeah. Points.
(laughter)
>> Ooh!
>> HARDWICK: Just to help him
transfer the money. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> HARDWICK: Michelle.
>> Um, this is the one,
actually, where she finds out
that Jon Voight's daughter is
gonna steal her man later.
(audience groaning)
>> HARDWICK: Oh. Shit!
>> What? Baba, baba, baba, boom!
>> HARDWICK: Oh! Yes.
>> Boom, boom, boom!
Close your legs to married men,
bitches!
(applause)
>> HARDWICK: And...
>> Sorry.
>> Rachel Donovan.
>> HARDWICK: We all know that
worked out great.